字幕: Takahiro Shimpo
校正: Takafusa Kitazume
私たちのチームは
ここの京都で
最新ゲーム機のゲームソフトを
開発しています
今日は そのユニークな発想とか
最先端の技術について
いくつかご紹介したいな
と思っております
我々が このプロジェクトを
始めるに当たって目標にしたもの
それが この和菓子です
和菓子のこの すっごく微妙な
なんというですかね
透明感とか
微妙な陰影
あとはこの何とも言えない
落ち着きのある存在感
こういうものを最新ゲーム機だからこそ
この質感にチャレンジできるように
なったんじゃないか
そう直感したからです
そのために こだわったのは
ライティング技術です
特にその透過感 透明感
っていうやつです
ちょっと見えますかね？
どうでしょう？
左にあるのが いわゆる
これまでのゲーム機でしか
できなかったことです
右が我々の最新技術で
今回 実現できるようになった表現です
ポイントは物の内部にまで
光りが当たった計算っていうのを
しかもゲーム機なんで
リアルタイムに行う という特徴があります
もう一つ 反射光
これも いままでなら
左のように中は
最新のゲーム機では
より自然な光の空間
っていうものに近づきました
更に
くぼみとか 境界部分っていうような
微妙な細部の陰影
こういうのも
再現できるようにしました
例えば これを
乗り物に適用するとこうなります
ちょっと微妙すぎて
このちっちゃい絵じゃ
分かりにくいかもしれないですね
すいません
キャラクターに適用すると
こういう感じになっていきます
一見すると
当たり前のことのように
思うんですけれども
実は こういう当たり前のことも
今までのゲーム機では
表現できませんでした
ただ こういうことを
一個一個積み重ねていくことで
先程の和菓子のような
落ち着きのある
存在感っていうことに
近づいていける
と考えております
ちなみに キャラクターのモチーフは
チェコの伝統的な
木彫り人形というのをモチーフにしました
手彫り感っていうところですね
これによる暖かみっていうのも
その再現も
最新のゲーム機だからこそ
実現できたと考えております
更に このゲームの世界観
題材なんですが
1960年代 っていうのを意識しました
現代に住んでる僕たちに
まあ 僕個人かもしれないですが
にとって 60年代っていうのは
すごいぶっ飛んだ
限界の方までぶっ飛んだ
イマジネーションに溢れた
憧れの時代なんですね
そういうエッセンスっていうのを
常々 ゲームに
なんとか入れれないか
っていうことを思ってました
ちなみに この画面は
このゲームに出てくる
シュールな顔をした島です
改めて このゲームの
基本の遊び方
っていうのを紹介しますと
ネットワークを使って
多人数で同時にプレイします
みんなで街を発展させて
独自の社会ってのを
築いてくのが目的です
街を建造するためには
資源が必要でして
その資源を見つけて 採掘する
というのが基本のプレイになります
もっぱら採掘方法は
ショベルとかピッケルとか
肉体労働です
採掘した資源っていうのは
街に持ち帰って
みんなでシェアします
これも まあ肉体労働です
持って運ぶ
仕事をはかどらせるためには
協力と役割分担
っていうのが
とても重要になってきます
もちろん これも肉体労働です
そして あるとき
ふと思ったわけです
もしかして「これって いわゆる
マルキシズム？」みたいな
最近でいうと本とか映画とかで
マルクスをテーマにしたものが
再評価されているわけですが
ゲームの世界では
まだ 誰もやっていないよね
ということで
じゃあ もっとその世界っていうのを
どんどん展開してみようじゃないか
ということで 他のゲームでは
やらないようなことを色々やってみました
例えば 行列
こんなものはデジタルの世界
ネットの世界でいうと
全く必要ないんですけど
敢えて その辺をやってみました
定期的にバスで通ってるんですが
それにもみんなで乗り合わせて
通勤していく
こんなんも ネットデジタル世界で
必要ないことなんですが
街には労働局と呼ばれる
施設がありまして
働きの貢献度
そういうのを評価されます
敵を倒したりすることは
もちろんなんですけど
物を持って運ぶ っていうような
ちっちゃいアクション
それらも全て
働きとして集計されます
更に街では時折
選挙が行われます
例えば これから
防衛施設を拡張するのか
発電設備を拡張するのか など
マニフェストがありまして
支持する候補者に投票することで
みんなで決めた街を
発展させていくことができます
他のメディアと違って
ゲームっていうメディアは
自分がその世界の中に入って
体験できる
っていうのが強みです
だから 「果たして本当に
私はこの社会の一員なのか」
「果たして 私は
この社会に貢献しているのか」
このゲームを通じて もしかして
こんな疑問を
抱く人もいるかもしれません
そんなゲームにしかできない世界
まだまだ もっともっとできることが
あると思うんですが
そういう未知のチャレンジっていうのを
これからも 我々はしていきたいな
と考えています
本日はどうもありがとうございました
(拍手)